now we do have some breaking news
moments ago actor Tom Hanks his wife
Rita Wilson they have tested positive
for coronavirus by the way they're in
our prayers tonight trace Gallagher he's
on our West Coast newsroom with the very
latest trace undecided about maybe two
three minutes ago and what's happening
here is Tom Hanks and Rita Wilson were
down in Australia they're filming Baz
Luhrmann's new movie about Elvis Presley
and Tom Hanks is playing the part of the
famous colonel who took care of Elvis
for many years and we were kind of
working this story earlier will now Tom
Hanks has just tweeted just moments ago
quoting here he says hello folks Rita
and I are down here in Australia we felt
a bit tired like we had colds and some
body aches Rita had some chills that
came and went slight fevers too to play
things right as is needed in the world
right now we were tested for coronavirus
and were found to be positive the
question now is what happens to them
down there well the answer appears to be
for medical officials they will have to
follow all the protocols meaning they'll
be tested
they'll be observed and isolated for as
long as the Australian public officials
want them to be it's unclear if they
will continue to actually work down
there and what the process and the days
that they will actually be under
isolation or quarantine in Australia and
what this means as far as their health
Shaun and how they are right now that's
also unclear but because of the tweet
and from the tone and tenor of it it
appears that they are upbeat and we are
are still looking for more information
on this and I just want to continue with
the breaking news here the NBA is now
suspending the season because of
coronavirus following tonight's game and
this comes in quoting here the NBA
announced that a player on the Utah Jazz
has preliminary tested positive for
kovin 19 coronavirus the test result was
reported shortly prior to the tip-off of
tonight's game between the Jazz in
Oklahoma City we had heard earlier that
the Oklahoma City game was cancelled and
the NBA wouldn't give us any explanation
as to why it was cancelled they just cut
the game off well now we know
that one of the jazz players has
preliminary tested positive for kovat 19
it goes on to say the Jazz the Oklahoma
City Thunder at Chesapeake Energy Arena
at that time tonight's game was canceled
the affected player was not in the arena
at the time the NBA is suspending
gameplay following the conclusion of
tonight's schedule of games until
further notice so it's unclear if they
are canceling the season or until
further notice the NBA has about twelve
thirteen fourteen games left in the
season the playoffs could be lengthy it
goes all the way until June late June
mid-june so we're talking about several
months the question now becomes is the
rest of the season canceled are they
just going to take a break for two weeks
or we just don't know the answers to
that Shawn a lot of breaking news on
coronavirus a lot of breaking news